what's up everybody I'm Nick scarpino
back with mr. Alfredo Diaz afraid of how
you doing here's a warden I know it's
been so long we haven't seen so far as
what soliders for ya and this this
little demo here just it just delivered
on what gears fans wanted right it's
that like great graphic yeah I mean so
let's let's take a step back for a
second it looks stunning it looks really
what what little of it we can see we
should also know that this is yeah you
know due to the fact that we're
streaming into the fact that you know we
have some constraints some of this might
appear a little compressed which means
that the darks are gonna be a little
darker than normal lux but right now is
definitely hard to see but bear with you
know this this this end this capped off
the microsoft conference which was a
fantastic conference to we didn't really
know what it was course I one knew it
was of course we all were thinking shows
you haven't seen gears in a while and
there yeah we're seeing we're seeing him
play it so there's proof positive this
actually as a real game and not cg I
thought anyone would think that but when
we see these new characters do we know
who these people are yet I honestly I
skipped out on the last one where they
had years thing where they had beer no
it was gives one two and three and then
there was a judgment oh that would had
beard with the blond guy right all right
yeah right skipped out on that one
wasn't really feeling that yeah for a
little bit i thought this character
might be jaime lannister from game of
thrones i was all very quickly that big
a color that that's probably not going
to be the case so we're in this spooky
environment scariest environment
imaginable yes um armies of course dark
and she's she's for some reason testing
this water yeah she's like drinking
handing out water so that's one of the
things i like thought the trail right so
you get the graphics right the high in
graphic so you know from from just the
previous gear series and the previous
games and then you also get like the
color commentary between the characters
yeah you got that right back and forth
yeah then it's just it's gritty just
like you know it's dark in know it's
just if your gears fan you got to be
happy with this yeah right yeah i mean i
don't want what you're gonna want more
you're gonna want to see what
multiplayer looks like but this is a
great start yeah i mean this is there's
this cast ensuing we're about to get
into it right now
let's skip ahead a little bit here if we
can no we don't know it looks like I
mean it's just that this is like really
take advantage of like next-gen right
here yeah but look at the the way like
the particles are flying around and then
like the weather it's awesome yeah I
mean it gives always been one of those
games that is very very cinematic you
know it kind of just about to say that
it's and this is this is proof positive
that they're not really stratum that
they don't necessarily need to you're
seeing the entire world fall out around
the sky our main character here and he's
just trying to find a little respite and
how do we get through here well mr.
chainsaw we gotta do that so that the
iconic weapon is back of course they're
not going to let that go I remember
originally of course when we saw that
the first time and it was just the most
oh and really violent thing I've ever
see the locusts oh my goodness you can't
let that go that that's what we call a
hashtag classic right there um and yes
there could they're continuing on to
this booking member of course made ever
so more spooky by the fact that it's
completely dark the old flashlight
mechanic never ceases to amaze me it's
just good I like that they're sticking
to the core of what like yours Awards
which is which is fun because i don't
know that i can't remember the last time
I really played gears you know uh you
know I got to be honest I think I play a
little bit of two I played all I loves
the coop aspect of it obviously that's
what that was probably the most fun
because you know you're talking about
the witty banter back and forth between
the all the plucky characters you get
cold tree and baby whoa this is this is
my absolute part of a favorite part of
this don't touch that and says and then
he just had a button prompt and touch it
of course and it jakey we having short
out his flashlight it was nothing good
can come of that right it's just good
seven this is exactly what I expected
right like we're ready we're gonna get
halo this year and then on top of that
it's like all right cool they announced
like the the remake for the previous
gears games and it's like all right we
what's what's gonna lead us in the next
year and so Gears of War yeah imma get
gears no I'm not I'm iske baad yeah
there's like this thing coming there's
like monster battles up the head you
know what are we seeing what are we
gonna see huh now the engine is just the
Unreal Engine is just so good yeah I
know it's working so well did it I mean
it's just it's got that slick look to it
I've always been a fan of that for sure
yeah and
just gruesome there we go yeah shocking
again remember active reloading and
everything really like if you time it
just perfectly you get like extra damage
on your bullets and stuff and there we
go well ladies and gentlemen obviously
more to come with cares of work afraid I
thank you so much for joining me chaos
what a great place to end it